e dopo essere stato un mese negli stati
uniti ragazzi ho documentato
tutto vi assicuro tutto ogni cosa è
stato il viaggio più bello di tutta la
mia vita senza esagerare ve lo giuro e
non vedevo l'ora di portarli con me per
mostrarvi quello che ho visto perché è
stato incredibile ragazzi questo è il
primo video chiama san francisco sono
appena atterrato all'aeroporto e ho
noleggiato la macchina che ne avrebbe
appunto portato poi in giro per tutti
gli states buona visione a tutti
[Musica]
fate j originals allora ragazzi devo
essere impazziti
appena
noleggiato
una mustang ho speso 1.200 dollari
devo essere impazzito completamento
praga è questa è la mia marci
no ma io non sto bene c'è proprio [ __ ]
fatemi vedere
mi sembra un tantino too much allora
questo dovrebbe essere il tasto di
accensione della macchina
senti come cambi allora signori gta ieri
al live è così bella ragazza tornando
65 miglia orarie
i carri
animals
[Musica]
ho preso una basta pagare perché di
vento a noi può
dire a vivo la mia vita è un quarto di
miglio alla volta arrivò a civita
capitale raga mi sono fermato un burger
king dottor beppe e si vola finalmente
ragazzo però non può che non mangiavo
sano
più bella
sono arrivati ragazzi incredibile
viaggio interminabile nacci uno stanco
morto come doveva quel letto è mio ma lo
porta a casa per noi la luce quando
sono troppo vecchio per queste cose non
ho effettivamente capito perché c'è un
lavandino fuori dal bagno sono uscito
dalla mio albergo questa è la prima
volta che vedo san francisco tutti
quanti posti dove si fa colazione aprono
alle 11 10 cioè prima non sanno cosa sia
la colazione a questo qua
dio benedica l'america non il direttore
del locale che si mette a fare le
flessioni a cazzo così perché vi andava
aiuto perché c'è la voglia storia ho
chiesto di andare al bagno e mai detto
che questo e ci hanno il codice alla
porta
perché c'è un pò gravi riportano il
testo sarà perché ci sono beni di prima
necessità paga ma che minchia di posto
incredibile è questo
anche lui ne sono un sacco ma ci costò
posto ma così è
ma che roba è
amici proprio lui proprio lui si
distingue vorrei tutto questo tasta
vetrina se è possibile anche se passate
mai da san francisco che sta vicino a
busto arsizio c'è un peer che si chiama
p al 39 che ne so io in tutte le altre
mia vita ho avuto un pò sono tutte le
mie vite possa tutte ragazzi pia 39 10
su 10 la pensavo così anche nelle altre
vite
cinque ragazzi che poggiano o meno bocci
spero che abbiano un sacco di sacchetti
per la mer allora ragazzi così faccio
una ripresa bella che sembra quasi un
vero youtuber noi siamo qua che poi c'è
il golden gate bridge è questo qua con
il signore che fa pandan col ponte è
pazzesco mai visto nella poesia
sarà che non veniva in america da un po
ma dopo tutta sta camminata ragazze io a
fort boeing che insomma la marca di una
lavatrice madonna sto con te infine non
finisce mai l'america è sempre sarà una
peste cose qua perché ogni tanto trovi
dei posti che non si è effettivamente
come minchia sia possibile che ci sia un
posto così può veramente fatto ben
madonna e grafica comunque e poi se i
videogiochi mi hanno insegnato qualcosa
nella vita che qua c'è la bourse fa il
secondo giorno a san francisco ancora
delle occhiaie e borse qua manco da
gucci e siamo finalmente giunti al
motivo per cui ho visitato san francisco
ragazzi che è la prigione di alcatraz
sono sempre stato super curioso di
visitarla ed eccoci qua e sarà nike a
trans perché c'è proprio questo odore di
gestore di ergastolo
ragazzi basta metterle canzoni col
capire che poi questa la fina comunque
segna madre vede sesto posto qua direbbe
che è comunque più pulito di casa mia
sto stupire entrando nel posto dove
andare a quella persona molto presto
qua ragazzi siamo nell'area ricreativa
che l'unica area dove si potevano pagare
il bottino una volta al giorno
a me non sembra che l'abbia perduto st
compagna
penso che noi abbia trovato un miliardo
ragazzi mai non l'ha vista una cosa così
e con questo ragazzi si concludono i
primissimi giorni di jet lag pieno a san
francisco e adesso con il mio bolide
andiamo verso una meta che ho desiderato
per un sacco di tempo ovvero las vegas
siamo a san francisco attualmente e devo
farmi 8 ore 44 minuti di viaggio per
arrivare a las vegas
ok ma se mi metto il car play ai acri
non funzionano galles persona
esattamente 900 km
tutto perfettamente bilanciato per
andarla a una città all'altra in america
non è come in italia
l'america perdi un giorno minimo peso
[Musica]
girovagando perla
mi aspetta lange
vista io ti perdono
al casinò e siamo arrivati
un
viaggio infinito la città che non dorme
mai io sì però da un po perché sto
guidando la stamattina ci sono la
madonna
hai chiamato quando un'onda di in testa
si paga ma il mio giardiniere sta roba
da faceva meglio
perché è tutto chiuso però io me ne
fotto entro lo stesso messo già non
dovrei essere qua
si no